was Pavarotti in particular and opera in
general something you were both already
interested in going into this or is it
something that was kind of new to you
well for me it was definitely something
I was interested in when I saw Pavarotti
idea that there may be a Pavarotti
documentary in the works while we were
working on the Beatles I said to Nigel
look if you don't call me
Pavarotti's please don't call me again I
wasn't quite there quite harsh but I was
really excited because my mother was a
amateur soprano and my grandfather was
also a soprano tenor an amateur tenor
and Pavarotti would play in a house
along with Mario Lanza and a couple of
other greats quite constantly so I was
very familiar with the music and I felt
like it was something that I wanted to
do I my father had been lucky enough to
meet him and talk to him many times and
spoke of him greatly so I really wanted
to do this film you know kind of a mum
really and how about you don't know how
did you come to be involved the I had a
friend in the late 80s who produced some
of Pavarotti's concerts in Europe in
football grounds I remember thinking an
opera singer in a football ground and I
buried that away and when this idea and
of course like all of us I'd come across
a Nessun Dorma there's a hundred million
people have watched Nessun Dorma on
youtube but I didn't know anything about
offer at the beginning and I know quite
a lot now how did they come to you then
how did you get started on it
well after Ron Howard and Paul and I and
our whole team finished the Beatles we
were looking for something else to do
and Universal Music Group Decca the
label of Pavarotti for 50 years that we
see in the film came up with a list of
ideas and we chewed this around and ran
it by Ron and Ron thought about it for a
while and we thought after doing the
Beatles what rock band do you do next
kind of thing is you know a step
sideways or sorry if you're a Stones fan
a step down but Pavarotti
that seemed really to run it not to I
speak for him but it seemed like a
really interesting challenge and that he
was curious and and and the rest you you
see making a movie that's both you know
interesting to people who are into
Pavarotti and into opera and making it
accessible
to newcomers which I mean I feel like
you guys really pulled off but was that
something you were concerned about and
how did you strike that balance well I
think actually Ron felt at the beginning
that we're all going pulled to a lesser
extent on a journey of discovery and
Pavarotti wanted to take opera to a
group of people that didn't know
anything about opera theory or high
opera or the high arts and we I think we
all wanted to make a film that did that
so you could watch this film not be an
opera fan obviously his personality
drives the story and come out of it
thinking oh well I think I rather like
this or that piece of music and if you
hear it on the radio it has a different
resonance and that was our goal
I got along without the idea obviously
as you want to embellish and continue
what he was doing what's always bringing
opera to the masses you know and you
also want to learn about the man and
hopefully knowing what you've learned
from him helps you makes you want to get
more into operate anyway just for the
sake of him and that voice but you know
to experience its some more that was the
goal we wanted to do is make everybody
like Pavarotti I wish I could have met
him when you finished the film I what
guy would have been great to hang out
with it would have been lovely to seen
him perform I wish I could have met him
that kind of feeling and that's what we
were trying to achieve and hopefully we
did I've read that it's sort of
structured like a piece of music and I'm
curious how early that came about how
much of that was dictated by Pavarotti
in his life and how much did you have to
kind of impose on the material if I may
please see if I get it right the these
kind of films different from a
single-issue documentary you're building
something about a life you start off
with some preconceptions very early on
Ron and Mark Monroe and I think Paul
were like the idea that if there was
parallels between opera plots and
Pavarotti's life that that would be
interesting it could be very contrived
and we went away from that and then when
things emerged we can't we came back and
just milked it in a few places but what
happens is you get the story laid out
and then things aren't working things
are working and you learnt a lot about
this person that you didn't know because
most people of this level of fame are
fantastically interesting people in all
every aspect of their lives and that's
what whether it's Bob Dylan or Pavarotti
or whoever it might be um so then we get
into a kind of a think tank process
which which Ron is absolutely brilliant
at leading he I remember um my friend
Jeff Rosen with whom I worked on the Bob
Dylan project saying that Bob Dylan as a
musician every musician that plays on
stage with him does their best work many
of them may be actually musically more
perfect than Bob and I would say about
Ron the way he was sitting these
documentaries and as a group of people
he has a way of having everybody feel
they can say their piece drawing it out
and then from time to time that's where
we want to go as Paul's saying and you
sort of realized actually the ship has
just turned a little bit and this
documentary turned quite a bit halfway
through I mean you know when you're
making a film about somebody like
Pavarotti or you know the fact that it's
a round opera the initial obvious thing
is well let's see how operatic we can we
can make this see if his life had a
natural three-act arc in itself in a
sense anyway so we were blessed by that
and then when we started to the
difference between doing like a rock
talk or from the editing point of view
or doing working with music operatic
music orchestral music is they don't
come in for bar sequences they very
rarely repeat sequences they're usually
always developing and always changing
and evolving so it's very difficult to
edit down so once you commit to a sound
up you can't just run away from
Pavarotti having given him a few bars
you have to allow the man's voice to
really do what it does and you want to
so you have to choose those moments
carefully but by doing that early on and
finding the idea was to find the right
opera piece that fits that where we are
in the film where this is the part of
the story here so this operatic piece a
piece of music that he's saying that we
can use the lyrics for that are going to
tie us in so we were very choosy in that
respect and we did that a couple of
times and suddenly realized hey we're
actually achieving this operatic turn
here we're allowing the Opera to give us
the emotion if you get the Opera to come
in and do take the place of some of the
story for you as it does
then that helps you achieve what you're
the emotion you're trying to achieve and
that's what we were going for at the
very beginning when we started this Paul
came to me he said you do realize that
we can't mix the music like we're doing
on on the Beatles you know you can go
into the help song which you probably
all know leave it behind have somebody
talking come back and you kind of know
what the song is but in order to
understand our vote Eleanor some piece
of music you you can't just dip in and
out when Paul said I don't know we can
do this Europe and then the first
rough-cut screening I sort of thought
well I never thought about the way the
music was running I said to Paul I think
you figured it out and he just smiled I
mean Paul is a completely brilliant
music editor amongst many other things I
have to say last question Oh No thank
you
maybe maybe the best in the world the
sound mix in general in this movie is
unbelievable and I'm wondering what the
process was and what the decisions were
in terms of preserving the integrity of
the original recordings but also sort of
applying things like Dolby Atmos or the
new technology to make it sound as good
as possible well it's very tricky
because of that because of the origins
of it all you know you're stepping into
an you know dangerous territory to start
remix in and giving people things
slightly differently however we're in a
new technological age that's easy for me
to say but so we've we were wonderfully
blessed that Dekker was gave us the 24
tracks of some of these things and
having Chris Jenkins and Sally Heder as
our team we got to mix her Abbey Road as
well we decided to try a couple of other
things taking ways to enhance the music
using current day technology to try and
just give it that extra lift we were
able to use a technology where they
spread specific mics around the room we
went into studio one at Abbey Road and
then played the performance just the
Pavarotti's voice and just the music and
just certain instruments and recorded it
with this surround and then chose the
atmospheres in a way to try and recreate
some of the shape of the orchestra and
his positioning of the voice with this
echo that you're creating yourself you
know in recorded in Atmos so there was
some few extra things where we didn't
really feel we were taking the liberty
enhancing and we tried it on a couple of
performances and it didn't help because
of the nature of the way that it was
recording we just couldn't separate it
enough but in the whole last reel is all
done in Studio One and that was just a
really great experience to be in there
and to be able to listen to all those
recordings in their raw form even the
three tenors is in their life in such a
fashion but I think I speak for everyone
when I say it's a beautiful movie and I
really appreciate you guys coming here
to talk with us